so here's what I'm going to do I'll go
to start your by just taking the
information in the question and then
just see what we got okay so we've got
these currencies a dollar ten dollars a
hundred goes up to a thousand right yeah
so we have this country it has these
currencies and the question is if I have
five hundred thousand that's half a
million of these notes I guess is it
possible to get a million dollars of
currency out of that so a million
question mark
can it be done okay now again this is a
this is such a great problem because
we're not used to can something happen
or not that's the sort of through-line
the thread between this question in the
previous one we used to find a number
like solve what how many do I need okay
so this is unfamiliar immediately
because the question is just weird
can it be done I'm going to introduce
some algebra in here our interpreter is
our tool for dealing with numbers when I
don't know what the numbers are so I
just give them a label and then I just
run with it okay so there's going to be
some number of dollar notes some number
of ten dollar notes some number of these
some of these okay so just going to give
them a name let's call them say P Q R
and yes okay so I don't know what any of
these are equal to but I know there's
going to be some number of them okay now
once you take all of those notes
together PE Q and it's what's the total
number of notes that I have on the board
500,000 right so if I had like say 125
thousand of these hundred twenty-five
thousand of these from the Treasury et
cetera they would have to sum they'd
have to add up to 500,000 half-a-million
so I can now create an equation that
relates all of these numbers together
I said 125 thousand because I divided
that by four because I know that they're
connected they're not just random
unrelated numbers so if I add these all
together then I should get 500,000 so
this is a start this is good this is
progress
it I want you to look at the question
now I have taken into account this piece
of information have a look at what else
we know because this is pretty much it
right what are the information have I
gotten the question that I have not
taken into account that I could form
into an equation any suggestions the
value over here is going to be million
dollars so I haven't touched this at all
so the question then becomes how do I
take that idea that concept and turn it
into something I can work with an
equation
I can't just pause there I want to have
did anyone write something like this a
path from P oh yeah okay a very small
number I hands down so what's going on
what is this what's Tina staying
together because we're going to finish
this equation together right what's 10 Q
what is the significance of 10 to you
it's thinking about this right Q is the
number of 10 dollah notes you've got the
number of ten dollars you've got so
therefore 10 Q is the total value of all
of your $10 notes does that make sense
you've got two of them if you had five
of them then the total value be 50 right
and you can say the same thing about
your hundred dollar notes what's the
value 100 are and the same of your
$1,000 1,000 s okay now this is equal to
as suggested the value the actual money
value okay so this is good this is more
progress I've got two equations now
that's really good
now just in a general rule of thumb I
didn't bring this with me but I might be
able to long yeah I could put and do
this I'm going to steal some tape up
just a general rule of thumb when you're
trying to solve for values right if you
have X number of variables you need X
number of equations to solve that let me
give you an example if I gave you sorry
I give you an easier example if I gave
you a single variable at a single
equation you could solve that right very
easy to find out what X is
but if I give you two variables or two
unknowns you can't just hold that right
because there's in fact an infinite
number of X's and Y's that will satisfy
this equation right what you need is you
need a second equation something like
say this and then you can get a solution
okay
my question to you is why why is it that
to get two variables you need two
equations
I've chosen X and y deliberately you can
represent these visually countries how
would I choose to represent something
like say this is an easy one how could
you represent this visually on something
like this what would this look like on
here it would be a straight line
wouldn't it in this case I've made the
numbers nice and easy for you it would
be y equals 2x minus 4 wouldn't it and
we know it 2x minus 4 looks like let me
just draw a rough on like that there is
y equals 2x minus 4 that's that line
this one's a little more messy what's
this going to look like 5y equals maybe
X plus 3 can you describe to me what
this looks like
what's it look like yeah it's slicing
down you've got a negative gradient is
it steep is it shallow it's pretty
shallow so I don't know something
something like this pika now this
picture tells you why there has to be
two equations to get to sorry to get two
variables can you see why if you want to
get a single unique solution where is it
on the diagram
it's the point of intersection isn't it
okay now that's why if I extend this if
I think about having say three variables
X plus y plus Z equals subject to X
minus y plus five then equals something
else okay if it says to reason that a
two variable system gives you straight
lines on a two-dimensional plane right
what can you think a three variable
equation gives you it doesn't give you a
straight line
two variables two dimensions yeah
and X&Y and up-down and a left-right
three variables so a three-dimensional
equation doesn't represent a line it
represents a plane okay so here's my
plane right and I can orient it
whichever way I want just like I can
orient my straight line whichever way I
want this is one of these okay if I have
two of these together right just like
these two exist together I will find
some points of intersection something
like this there we go okay I'll try and
hold this as neatly as I can
oh yeah okay so you can see my two
planes intersecting together you see
that pretty much it up yep now if I'm
looking for a solution and X and a Y and
it said this is not enough information
can you see why why is it not enough
sorry I should have chosen something a
little more rigid why isn't this enough
information yeah if I hold it exactly
this way what you're doing now hold that
straight as much as I could I I don't
have enough fingers obviously is you're
looking right down the beam you'll see
that you'll hear right down the barrel
of all the points of intersection does
that make sense and they form a straight
line as a suggestion okay so that's why
if you want to find a unique solution
and I definitely don't have no hand to
this you need a third plane right you
need something like I'm actually not
going to put one here because a third
plane might not intersect it could be
somewhere else okay